The alcoholic, dimension-hopping mad scientist
Rick Sanchez could be called a lot of things.
"Compassionate," "friendly," and "filled with
basic human decency" are not among them.
"Hey, Jerry, don't worry about it.
So what if the most meaningful day of your
life was a simulation operating at minimum
capacity?"
Over two seasons, Rick and Morty have killed
countless people, destroyed whole civilizations,
and just made some pretty terrible life decisions.
Here are some of the worst things Rick and
Morty have ever done.
Murdered a bunch of bureaucrats
Rick's brazen disregard for most everything
is established in the pilot, when he drags
Morty out of class for an expedition to Dimension
35C so Rick can use him to smuggle some powerful
Mega Seeds through interdimensional customs.
"And I'm gonna need you to put them waaaay
up inside your butthole, Morty."
"My butt?"
"Put them way up inside there, as far as they
can fit!"
"Oh geez, Rick."
But their plan doesn't work out, so Rick has
to commandeer a portal home while Morty engages
in a shootout with the customs officials.
Morty ends up killing dozens of aliens with
personal lives and loving families.
"They're not robots, Rick!"
"It's a figure of speech, Morty!
They're bureaucrats.
I don't respect them."
Blew up the Zigerions
Kidnapping people isn't the nicest way to
get secrets, but you can't help but like the
Zigerions in Episode 4 of the first season.
After a series of simulations within simulations,
the alien scammers maneuver Rick into a situation
where he gives up the recipe for concentrated
dark matter…
"Grab that bucket!
OK, two parts plutonic quarks, one part cesium."
...but as usual, Rick is one step ahead of
them the whole time.
The Zigerions try out the recipe… and blow
up their entire ship.
Which would have been bad enough, but of course
the show adds this little tidbit right before
they all die:
"And listen, I'm sorry for yelling earlier.
I couldn't ask for a better staff.
I love you guys!
And I love all your families."
Man, it's like Rick can only destroy things
with families.
Cronenberged the world
Rick's done some pretty bad things, but leaving
an entire reality in the grip of horrible
suffering might be one of the worst.
After inadvertently making the entire population
of Earth fall violently in love with Morty,
Rick fixes the problem with a little science.
"What are we gonna do, Rick?!"
"We're gonna be fine, Morty, relax.
I whipped up an anecdote.
It's based on praying mantis DNA."
When that turns everyone into bug-monsters,
Rick fixes the problem with better science.
"It's koala, mixed with rattlesnake, chimpanzee,
cactus, shark, golden retriever and just a
smidge of dinosaur.
Should add up to normal humanity."
That's when the episode gets dark.
Rick's new serum also backfires, but do Rick
and Morty stick around to fix things?
Nope!
They just abandon everyone in the world to
a lifetime of suffering and take the places
of their dead selves in an alternate reality.
"Rick!
What about the reality we left behind?!"
"What about the reality where Hitler cured
cancer, Morty?
The answer is 'don't think about it.'"
Created Abradolf Lincler
The first season finale introduced a ton of
new awesome characters, like Bird Person and
Squanchy.
"Is there a good place for me to squanch around
here?"
"Squanchy, you can squanch wherever you want
to, man!
Mi casa es su casa, dawg!"
"Alright!"
But the strangest guest at the party has to
be Abradolf Lincler, a mutant creation with
the combined DNA of Abraham Lincoln and Adolf
Hitler who was abandoned by his father-slash-god,
Rick.
The existential pain of this guy is just off
the charts, and Rick, being Rick, couldn't
care less.
Even when Abradolf Lincler sacrifices himself
and things get emotional and people start
crying, Rick's only got one thing to say:
"But at least he didn't die in vain.
He got these crystals.
And these babies just saved this lame-ass
party!
Wubba-lubba-dub-dub!"
Because there's nothing like sacrifice and
emotional torment to kick off a party, right?
Abandoned Jerry forever
The Cronenberg episode left the original version
of Jerry in a mutated hellhole, but Rick wasn't
done with the guy.
In season 2, episode 2, Rick drops him off
at a facility that basically amounts to a
giant daycare for Jerrys.
Dozens of versions of Jerry wander around
in various states of confusion and distraction,
waiting to be picked up again.
But one room contains all the Jerrys who were
completely abandoned by their Ricks and Mortys.
"These are the Jerrys whose Ricks and Mortys
never came back."
These guys are stuck in a nursing home on
an alien planet.
Forever.
Talk about depressing.
Created and destroyed a universe
Rick's got a pretty heavy god vibe going throughout
the series, and nowhere is that more apparent
than in his choice of car battery — which
contains an entire universe whose sole purpose
is to...well, power his car.
"You have a whole planet sitting around making
power for you?!
That's slavery!"
"That's society!
They work for each other, Morty."
Basically, Rick's car battery contains an
entire civilization of sentient, intelligent
beings… who happen to be so intelligent
they make another battery with its own micro
universe.
And Rick has zero problems smashing that battery
to pieces, killing the civilization inside.
"Oh, hey guys.
I just finished cooking us a feast!"
"You monster!"
Yup, that's all of these guys, and their families,
smashed out of existence.
By the time Rick and Morty escape the car
battery, all the creatures inside know that
they're slaves...and they have no choice but
to keep their meaningless existence going.
"One of two things was gonna happen: I was
gonna have to toss a broken battery.
Or the battery wouldn't be broken."
Is this guy the worst yet?
Almost...but there's more.
Because there was also the time Rick and Morty...
Slaughtered innocent aliens
In season two's penultimate episode, Rick
and Morty stop for windshield wiper fluid
on a planet which is about to commence "The
Festival."
"You've been able to sustain world peace because
you have one night a year where you all run
around robbing and murdering each other without
consequence!"
"That's right!"
"What?!"
"It's like The Purge, Morty!
Th-That movie, The Purge!"
Rick convinces Morty to stick around and watch
the Purge, and they try to save a girl, and
it all backfires when they get caught up in
the middle of the mayhem.
"It's the hardest-working liver in the galaxy,
Morty.
Now it has a hole in it.
I hope it was worth it."
"I was just trying to do right!"
"Yeah, well that's not really the theme of
tonight's party.
Heads up."
In the end, they strap on a pair of powered
battle suits and go to town on the townsfolk,
killing just about everyone.
"You're really going for it over there.
I, uh, think, uh, I think those people were
just hiding."
"I don't give a s---!"
Put deadly bacteria in ice cream
If there's anything Rick cares about, it definitely
isn't Jerry.
And we got solid proof of that in season two's
eighth episode, which opens with Jerry in
an alien hospital, projectile-spewing toxic
vomit.
"Watch out for that stuff.
It'll stain if it gets on your clothes, and
it'll send you on a murderous rage if it gets
in your eyes or mouth."
...which happened because Rick stored some
mutant bacteria in a pint of Cherry Garcia
ice cream.
And because of that, Jerry comes close to
getting castrated so his genitals can serve
as another guy's heart transplant.
But in the end, as terrible a guy as Rick
may be, one thing's for sure: He always has
the situation under control.
"Bwanuh-dun-nuh-nuh nuh nuhhhh.
Bwah nuh, nuh-nuh-nuhhh."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!